absolutely
[Music]
[Music]
oh what a LED well today you're in for
an absolute treat as I have one of the
best players and Lads in World rugby
he's the face of rugby and Argentina and
the brutal loose forwarders by all
accounts one of the nicest guys you'll
meet he's very well traveled and he's
had an incredible career to date he is
one of the absolute greats it is Pablo
Matera welcome mate
are you James thank you for having me
mate thanks for coming on I've had so
many requests to get you on especially
since your time at the Crusaders
um you're a very popular man here in New
Zealand
no it's a pleasure it's a pleasure
rugby always a pleasure and he gets my
my English is good to just speak my
English every time in a while not to
lose it so yeah yeah your English is
good
um I notice it in your time at the
Crusaders I wasn't sure what English was
like heading to the Crusaders but
um obviously you're fitted in there
seamlessly
yeah English is not too bad I learned
when I was young but I thought I speak
better and when I arrived in New Zealand
I just couldn't understand nothing the
guy was saying so I had to like learn it
all again that's a different a different
English you guys speak the one I learned
so but now I'm I improve a little bit
and and I'm able to speak with you guys
so it was it was something good as well
yeah I guess there's so many slang words
or words that you don't really see in
the dictionary that people use a
yeah yeah probably a couple of them here
but you're just coming off the rugby
Championship uh a very evenly contested
um competition this year
um how did you find it with Argentina
I was wonderful it's always a pleasure
to play with Argentina and and be part
of the rugby Championship
it's obviously a very tough tournament
uh but it's always always a lot of
learning and we we got a big challenge
this year because we had a new head
coach with Michael Chica and yeah a lot
of a lot of new players as well young
players uh joining the team so it was a
big challenge but I think that we we've
been growing week by week we had some
some great games on the way and and I'm
sure that the team is in a good spot to
keep on growing so yeah we really
enjoyed it and I think that we take the
most of this tournament and one of the
highlights from that tournament
obviously would have been that win
against the All Blacks down in
Christchurch how was that one
oh that was the best one that was one
probably one of the games uh I will
always remember uh going back to
Christchurch after being there for six
months living with my family and going
back to Christchurch to play the All
Blacks uh in the orangutan stadium that
was something special and I think there
was not a game that I wanted to win more
than that one so yeah it was a dream
come true to be able to to beat the
oblige for the for the first time in in
New Zealand territory as well so yeah it
was a big guy like right yeah and
International Rugby is so close at the
moment so evenly contested I mean all
the Northern Hemisphere times that had
the
um June Internationals they were all
really close competitions and then
obviously
um the rugby Championship as well any
team can be any team at the moment in
the international level
yeah I agree and that was one of the
things that we spoke at the beginning of
the tournament like there's a big
opportunity now in in war rugby you you
turn on the TV and you watch any game on
uh every every team every team is
stronger and it's more even at the
moment so you could see the in the
northern fear of being such a good rugby
and now we're at the start of the rugby
Championship uh you could see one game
Beach win one game each so yeah I think
a rugby is getting is playing very very
competitive at the moment and it makes
for an exciting World Cafe like Rugby
World Cup next year
um I mean I'm guessing Argentina feeling
pretty confident about their chances
heading into that uh competition knowing
how even all the teams are
yeah yeah obviously that's that's a long
way to go still but I think we were in
the we are in the good in a good
position to to keep on growing we have
everything that that a team needs to to
be a strong team so I'm sure we're gonna
get there in a good place yeah who do
you see is the favorites for the Rugby
World Cup at the moment who who do you
think is going to be the hardest team to
be
hard to tell but I would say if I had to
choose one now probably France or
Ireland I think they are the top teams
in the Northern Hemisphere and the
southern hemisphere at the moment you
you can't sell which one is the
strongest team probably South Africa or
New Zealand at the moment so yeah I I
would choose I will pick maybe maybe
France at the moment yeah France at home
they're going to be extremely tough to
be they're playing some really good
footy
yeah it's gonna be awesome for them but
it's also a lot of pressure for sure
playing back home so I'm sure anything
can happen so yeah you guys you're not
starting against France
first game yeah to open the competition
it's gonna be there's gonna be some game
to start uh
yeah good starter yeah and who's in
Argentina's pool
they got a tough pull like I know I
remember last year yeah a really tough
pull
with France
this one is still South we go to Japan
we've got England as well so it's gonna
be it's gonna be tough but yeah we're
starting against England that's gonna be
a big game yeah big game for us as well
yeah right oh I can't wait for the Rugby
World Cup it's gonna be it's gonna be
awesome but then you're off to
um Japan with Honda heat um how did this
how did this contract come about
well uh actually I was playing on Steam
steam at least one more season we could
say this and then then this opportunity
came
[Music]
um
I was playing a lot of rugby this year
I've been playing a lot of rugby and I
remember my I was a bit concerned about
how much rugby I've been playing and
obviously
I remember for the last World Cup we
played the final against the Crusaders
in 2019 I played a lot of rugby I play
Super Rugby that year I went straight to
to World Cup and to rugby championship
and to World Cup and uh I remember
playing the workout on Phoenix Austin
and I said like this is not the way it's
supposed to be I should be like I should
be preparing the whole year to play the
World Cup not coming to the World Cup
already with
with the sore body and an exhausted but
so I think it was a it was a it was a
hard decision because obviously
I had the best time ever at the
Crusaders and I didn't want to leave
leave my spot there I really enjoyed
I loved it but I thought that Japan was
Japan was maybe the the smartest
decision in a World Cup year and I
always wanted to go to Japan I I thought
it was going to be maybe after a couple
of more years but the opportunity came
now I thought it was a good time to do
it my wife loves loves Japan she's been
there on holidays and she came to the
World Cup as well and she left sick so
she she she was one of the she that put
the took the decision strongly and we
said okay let's go for it we love new
challenges uh going to New Zealand was a
bit was a big challenge as well and we
really enjoyed it and we learned a lot
so we just say okay let's take this
chance to to keep on learning and
I don't know experience something
different yeah mate your wife must be a
legend because obviously so much moving
you've done in your career to still be
up to challenges to head to countries
where obviously another language you're
going to have to learn
um it's not easy for your partner and
especially once you've got kids as well
yeah my parents
were like he was born in France yeah he
lived there almost for eight months then
we went to Argentina new language for
another six months then we went to New
Zealand another language a third
language for six months
and now I'm taking them to Japan so yeah
they they've been awesome they are the
best support ever so they allowed me to
do the things that I love the most and
we we do it all together so yeah I told
I told I told my wife maybe after the
the after my next contract we settled
somewhere but now I just have to go be
in a raw electric experience Everything
to learn new things and I think it's the
best is the best time to do it with a
small kid yeah we have another one
another kid on the way oh yeah right so
yeah thank you so probably probably soon
we'll have to stop moving so much
is that another boy or girl or you're
not sure yet
now we've got another boy oh another boy
oh my Argentina rugby is in good hands
yeah he's gonna be called Akira like oh
nice
yeah okay because it's a Japanese a
Japanese name and he's gonna be born in
Japan so yeah we'll go for it oh mate
love that and um
speaking uh talking about the languages
and stuff like have you can you speak
any Japanese I know you gave um tereo uh
attempt over here or you got stuck into
learning today which was pretty
impressive I don't know a lot of people
were blown away by you even trying to um
speak today which is awesome how's your
Japanese
oh my Japanese is not that good but I
I promised myself that I will learn a
little bit for sure yeah we're gonna
take lessons I think it's important to
to be able to really get involved in a
new culture a new environment I think
it's important that at least you try
your best to yeah to understand the
language and their culture and yeah it's
it's a it's a big challenge my wife
she's very good with languages every
every time we go to a new a new country
she she learns the language perfectly
it's good when you need to make a call
to the TV guy or
pay the electricity bill or whatever
she's the one doing that because you
manage the language better than me but
yeah we're gonna try we're gonna try to
learn Japanese for sure and is that why
you try to learn today as well because
you just wanted to immerse yourself into
the culture
yeah to be honest in New Zealand it's
amazing like as soon as you arrive to
the to the airport you start seeing uh
you you could see uh the two languages
everywhere yeah into the Maori language
yeah English like Orchard New Zealand
every everywhere you see the two
languages and like uh I got it I got a I
got interested in in learning more with
we buy a book a big book uh it's like a
kids book and we read like every night
two or three pages and learn new words
and yeah and yeah we really enjoy it and
then when we see those words somewhere
in a movie or whatever we say oh I know
that word
yeah so it was really interesting and
yeah now we we brought the book back to
Argentina we give already and every once
in a while before bed with my son
he he learned a lot as well I remember
when we had to learn when I had to learn
the attack
the hacker for the Crusaders I had to
practice a lot at home and my son saw me
practicing so he almost knew it as well
and yeah that was that was amazing so
yeah obviously I think it's a it's it's
a big opportunity to be in a new place
and learn the language as well yeah so
what's it like facing the hacker now
that you know a little bit of um teddo
and a little bit of the Maori culture
and obviously you learned the Crusaders
hacker
now I know a little more about what's
the what's the meaning of it the the
only thing I knew before is like oh yeah
it's like it's like a it's like a war
chance they do and yeah but you don't
really know you don't really know too
much and uh now being in being involved
in the New Zealand culture and knowing
how strong it is to be involved in one
and how you feel like
the energy of the environment changes
when when the boys are about to do it
and uh the meaning of it why they do it
and everything is just it's just
unbelievable and I enjoy it now I just
watch it and I enjoy it I I feel like
okay I'm
yeah I'm happy that I'm able to
experience that and to see the boys
doing it and it's just it's just Joy man
it's so cool and one thing I do like to
do um through all my episodes is to hear
a little bit more about
um the guests as a young fellow what it
was like for them growing up so
um obviously you're my first guest from
Argentina so obviously a very different
upbringing to a lot of kiwis that I've
had on before but
um what what is it like growing up in
Argentina what was your upbringing like
oh it was wonderful
a lot of Outdoors or activities trying
to learn every sport
a lot of football a lot of football here
like I started playing rugby when I was
15 years old before that it was all
about football here in Argentina and
as a young kid if you want to make
friends you need to to know how to play
football
yeah I was a bit uh
a bfr rebel when I was when I was young
as well
my mother is my mother is an angel poor
poor poor woman he had to do so much for
me and I I was not an easy boy I was not
easy boy
I lost my father when I was 12 so I was
a bit like a
too much Freedom too much freedom to be
honest my mother had to take care of our
stuff
and I had a lot of a lot of freedom no
one watching and doing all kind of
things but it was good it was it was I
lived in the countryside of Argentina
had a lot of friends a big school with a
lot of kids and now I had plenty of
friends from there got involved in rugby
when I was 15 and got Amazed by the
sport how different it was to everything
else that I experienced before being
able to be part of something bigger of a
big team
again to getting to to know new people
as well new friends
learning about the values of rugby and
yeah it's been
it's been an awesome childness childhood
to be to be honest I really enjoyed and
it's a
it's a bit wild in Argentina sometimes
maybe a bit unsafe now that I'm I'm a
father I said like I'm not sure if I
will let my my son to do all the stuff I
do when I was younger to have so much
Liberty but but it's it's a beautiful
country as well wonderful people and and
I really enjoyed my
joke with you I was I was very uh very
lucky here so what sort of travel were
you getting into we sort of getting into
fights and things like that or um what's
what's travel look like over there
uh when I was younger more like naughty
things I don't know uh
getting to inside houses that people
were not living there or uh buildings or
whatever just broken stuff or that kind
of stuff when I was a bit more like a
more a teenage teenager I get into some
fights and there was one when I was 17
that almost
almost pushed me away from rugby I
remember one of my under under 20s
coaches that told me like if you're
gonna be behaving like this uh this
that's not a
you you can't be part of a team rugby
team or whatever and at that point I say
like okay I need to I need to change
some attitudes I need to
start I don't know moderate mature
mature yeah more mature and really take
this more seriously so yeah that kind of
stuff like
uh having done any any crime or anything
like that but hey I was an naughty guy
with a naughty boy with too much too
much freedom to be honest no one to tell
me that I couldn't do this or that so I
just did whatever I could do whatever I
wanted and
most of the time that was getting into
trouble and when you first had a crack
at rugby I mean obviously were you a big
guy you would have loved the physical
side of the game I'd imagine
yeah yeah obviously uh I was not one of
the biggest guys I think I never been
one of the biggest guys uh I had my
first chance to play for a Pumas when I
was 20 yeah so and I played against
South Africa so to be honest I was
really afraid I remember the night the
night before uh
I was going to play players like Albert
he was playing Seven for South Africa he
was like 120 something kg and I was 96
kg
and I was like
how I'm gonna do how I'm gonna be able
to do this and yeah it was not too bad
it was not a too bad game for myself and
after that I started losing fear you
know when you start playing at at this
level you start losing fear a bit and I
keep on
developing my body as well getting a
little bit more uh better training
better nutrition more physical
a little bit heavier as well at the
moment
and yeah start building my game as well
so yeah
so when you um when you were named in
the Argentina side was it out of nowhere
how did you find out you'd made the
squad
um you said you're only 20 years old so
and were you expecting it or did it come
come out of nowhere
no that came out of nowhere I was
playing under 20s in France
and I received a call and say like okay
you need to come to Puma's Camp straight
away to train because the one of the
coaches wants to want to put the young
guys young guys in the in the squad just
to for them to start learning
that guy was Graham Camry
you know the coach yeah yeah yeah so he
he came from New Zealand to he was an
assistant coach for the Pumas and he
said like why don't you have like young
guys training with with experienced guys
yeah and we didn't have any any and he
said you need to have at least I don't
know five or six 20 years old guys
starting to learn trying to develop so
he was the one that changed the mind and
brought a major head coach bring some
some young guys so I went to Camp I
wasn't expecting to play and players
start getting injured and our captain at
the moment uh Fernando he was injured
like on a Tuesday when we were when we
were playing against South Africa so I
just jumped into the squad on a Tuesday
and I say okay that's it I think I'm
gonna play against South Africa and that
was and that was my debut yeah that was
my day
that's correct and you always play
Whenever you play for your country mate
you always play with so much passion
um you obviously love representing your
country and was it the same from as soon
as you're uh picked in that Squad
yeah 100 like
we represent obviously our country but
also we represent like a
our family you know how much things my
my mother did for me to be able to be to
be there uh represent my home club uh I
was a naughty boy I think that in any
other club in the world they would they
would just kick me out and they they
just embraced me the way I was so yeah
when I play for Argentina all that come
to my mind like
all the people that make it make it
possible and help me to to be there at
that moment
so yeah that's why we yeah we're not
playing foreign country we represent so
so many people that need something
beautiful and at the same time I think
you're 20 as well when you get a
contract offer over and at the list of
tigers
um was this an easy decision for you to
take up
uh what's the easiest decision I ever
took in my life like I was
I was playing my last game in the rugby
Championship we were playing against the
Australia in Argentina and I remember
one of the of the more experienced guys
marcosa he was a pro for Less attire and
he came and said like hey the head coach
of Leicester Tire
um Richard cockery is asking for you and
he he told me to ask you if you were a
king to come to Leicester and I said
like when and he said whenever you
you're available okay tell him I'm
coming so I I don't even like read a
contract or whatever he sent me a
contract and I just grabbed the contract
and gave it to my captain I was a
Fernandez Lobby yeah and I just gave
gave you gave him the contract say okay
you read this contract and tell me if
it's fine and yeah I just sign it sure
so I just signed the contract and after
signing the contract I called my mother
and said hey mother I'm I'm going to
play in Leicester tiger uh when I'm
going on Monday and she was like what
are you what are you talking about
um you have nothing to worry about uh
for another law we already read the
contract everything is fine I'm going to
play For Less attires so I just my mom
freaked out she drive she she drove to
to Rosario like three hours and a half
because he couldn't speak with me in the
phone I said like what are you telling
me and that's when I turn it on I'm
going to let the tiger it's a team in
England and when I go play professional
rugby for the first time in my life
and I was supposed to to be picked up at
the airport in Heathrow but when I
arrived there there was no one because I
think that the the flight got delayed or
whatever so I just started asking there
to the people I think how do I go to
Leicester and they were like Leicester
Leicester Square or Leicester city
because there's like a Subway a Subway
uh stop that is called Leicester
Leicester Square I almost went there
imagine if I went there I would never
ever find my way to Leicester let's
still be there oh yeah I remember I just
changed some uh dollar for pounds got an
hour of Internet went into a into a
computer and sent an email I only had an
email from Leicester and I said hey guys
I'm I'm at Heathrow Terminal Two I'm
gonna wait one more hour if not I'm just
finding my weather and after like 45
minutes someone arrived some guy arrived
and took me to to Leicester I was like
two hours and a half or three hours from
from Heathrow so I was I was lucky I
arrived I arrived soon I made it to to
the club
oh that's so good uh one of the great
Yarns and then once you made it there
what was it like what was it like going
in there as a 20 year old
um first time playing professional rugby
um must have been pretty cool yay
you were crazy like I
I didn't think too much before taking
decisions so I just went there I didn't
know even where I was going to live yeah
so they just put me on the house of
another player Gonzalo Camacho he was
like 31 years old living with with his
with his partner and I just went there
lived there for a month because no one
wanted to rent me an apartment to uh 20
years old rugby player with an
Argentinian passport no one wanted to
visit America in England I didn't have
like a bank account I didn't have
nothing so it was hard to get an
apartment
so I lived with him for a month he was
he was great help and after that I
started Living by myself that was like
the first time I lived by myself
remember that in England like they send
you letters like post letters for
everything like electricity bill or I
don't know everything is like a letter I
never opened one letter in my life like
the letters keep coming coming and like
after four months I was living in
Leicester my my mother came to visit and
when she opened the door there was like
a mountain of letters and she said like
what is all this and I said I don't know
like never opened a letter never paid a
bill never did nothing I didn't know how
I didn't know how to do it yeah
she took care of everything she had to
take care of everything but it was a
great experience like a lot of learning
from my time in Leicester yeah I I
struggled a lot because it was It was
obviously hard but now I I Look
Backwards and and it was incredible
incredible learnings I made a lot of
friends I think one of one of my friends
has been here in the podcast before uh
Scott Steely from Harrison okay yeah
yeah
or he was
he was the best he was the first guy to
come speak to me he said hey who are you
we play Under 20s against each other
yeah that year that year as well and the
year I went to Leicester so he was he he
took me uh under his wing and showed me
around and we had a lot of fun yeah we
had a lot of fun together no he's out my
he is a champion later he like he would
have been a good man yeah get you under
his wing because he loves a good time as
well so I could imagine you and him
having a good time as young 20 year old
kids
um enlisted together but you mentioned
um you obviously learned a lot about
life off the field you grew up pretty
quick living by yourself but what was it
like on the field over there was it was
it a different style that you weren't
used to
yeah it was like my first and I've never
been in football like in a professional
uh Team so everything was new and
Leicester is a it's an amazing place to
to start as a young player because it's
very very professional
so everything was learning I remember
one the one of the interns there one of
the snc coaches uh
asked me like what what I was having for
dinner and I remember I I didn't know
how to cook or whatever so I just went
to the petrol station by some there was
like a combo where you can buy a monster
drink energy drink and it came with some
with a sandwich and chips and I remember
like one every two nights I ate that I
didn't know anything about nutrition and
when the snc coach knew about this he
said I know this you need to start
eating properly he he took me to the
supermarket he showed me everything that
I need to buy and put everything on the
cards make me pay okay after this day
every time you come to a supermarket you
buy exactly the same things I just put
in your car I remember me trying to put
some Pringles put some pictures and he's
like no this now this is not you can't
check this and that was a game changer
that was a after that I put like start
putting a lot of weight start gaining a
lot of uh muscle uh muscle weight and
that change that changed everything I
was sitting like very bad before that I
didn't know anything about nutrition so
yeah that was one of the big learnings
and what was it like on the field did
you did you get much game time
um for Leicester obviously we were young
it was a pretty um it was probably a
Powerhouse of English rugby at the time
so did you get many opportunities on the
field
yeah I now know that I I Look Backwards
I think I bought a lot of opportunities
for I played like nine nothing or 10
games
but at that moment I thought like I need
to play every game yeah so I remember
being angry because I was not playing
every game and I remember Richard Coco
is telling me like you're a young player
you're just developing now you're maybe
not playing too much but when we were
when you are gonna get older you're
gonna say oh I would wish I played less
rugby and I was like nah I had to play
every game every game every game I
didn't understand it now that I look
backward I said like he made me play
quite quite a bit I went for a medical
Joker for tomcroft he did his he did his
knee and I think that
no one expect me to play too much and I
I had a couple of chances a couple of
games and so yeah I think I played I
played quite a bit and then the next
movie for you was back to Argentina was
it to the local uh Super Rugby team is
it the huguarius is that how you
pronounce it
yeah but that was the year that was like
two years after Leicester because when
the when the seasons
was about to finish uh Richard cokery
asked me like okay what do you want to
do do you want to come here for one more
season
Jowers was not still a possibility
General was two years after that so and
I said like I'm not sure I'm not sure I
wasn't able to make the decision yeah so
I I told him okay I'm going back home
when the season ends I'm going back home
I'm gonna take a couple of weeks and
then I I talk to you and tell you if I
want to come back or not yeah so I I put
all my stuff in a car
I parked the car anywhere and I just
left England went back home to my
friends and said like okay I need to
take a decision I never took the
decision I never was able to okay I'm
gonna I'm gonna come back while I'm not
gonna come back yeah went back to play
for Argentina rugby Championship without
a contract without nothing broke my
shoulder
and after that I I've been like 10
months without playing rugby
because I I did my shoulder and now
looking backwards I said like I was
taking all the wrong decisions like why
would you go why would you you had to do
one more year and let's learn a little
more role play rugby Championship with a
contract so you're safe yeah but all
that stuff I didn't think about all that
at the at that time I just I don't know
do whatever so
so you had to go back to Argentina leave
back with my mother my three sister for
10 months without playing rugby without
doing just recovering and being back in
Argentina so
when I saw that my career was doing like
this playing for the Pumas Playing For
Less tired and boom I hit the wall went
back home and yeah next year was was
World Cup uh and I still like oh I need
I need to get I need to start training
get fit and get ready if I want to have
a chance so I played the Pacific cup
after that pacific cup after my my
recovery Pacific up in Fiji and some
games that the Argentina had like a
Argentina 15. I went to the I went to
the World Cup and after the World Cup
that's when when Jaguar started and I
played four year for the Jaguar but in
the middle of Javas and Leicester there
was a year where I was just injured
without a contract living with my mother
yeah yeah right it's crazy so when you
when you are injured like that there's
no one from Argentina help you with your
you know recovery and stuff is it all
left for you to do on your own
that was a bit crazy because with
Argentina before Jaguars you didn't have
like a contract because there was no
professional competitions you just
you got a contract for the week if you
get picked for for the squat or or if
you are between the so there was there
was
uh how to tell there was a not that I
didn't have a professional contract with
Argentina whatever I was just by myself
yeah they did help me a lot put it with
the I went they they had a place where
you I could go have recovery do a
physical therapy and all the stuff so
yeah obviously they help with my
recovery but I was not under a contract
or something that now I was just like by
myself yeah that's crazy and did you
ever pick up your um car with all your
stuff in it or is it still there no no I
remember like after like an year or so I
received a email an email that said like
okay we found we found your car it was
wrongly parked or I don't know how much
time so we just I think I demolish it oh
sure
yeah yeah it was
it was a 300 pound Fiat uh Fiat Punto
from 1999 with all my stuff inside and
it only only one of the doors uh was
working
because
at that moment for Less attire
on a night out he just smashed the door
and I could never open it again so only
the only my door the driving door was
the one working so every time I had to
pick someone up that the the guy had to
come
this way into the other side
so yeah I I didn't lost a lot of value
when I lost my Carver yeah I got I
remember I have my coffee machine and
some stuff inside the car as well that
yeah they're gone
get it but one one thing about the um
haki Warriors was that well obviously
it's always hard to start a new team in
a competition like Super Rugby but one
thing I guess I remember about them is
they were getting better every single
year I guess it was
um the time you guys had together and
obviously you took them all the way to
the to the final in 2019 but it was such
a cool
um Journey for you guys to see where you
went from the start to we finished up
uh there was some believer like uh I
remember when when we studied the
project uh when they told us hey you
guys want to join the Java Wars and and
our first year we didn't have nothing we
didn't even have like a gym a proper gym
where we would train or anything it was
it was from zero
and the first year we struggled a bit I
think we won
three or four games
second year with we won like six yeah I
know third year we played qualifying us
we couldn't believe we were playing
quarter finals in the URS program
against the Lions
and our fourth year we went to the final
so it was it was a lot of growing year
by year and yeah it was amazing like we
were feeling really proud of what we
were doing because we looked backwards
and
we started building building like a
culture our team has a kind of a culture
already has to have some traditions have
some ways of working uh learned a lot I
remember our first year we said like
okay guys we're gonna come into a
competition where all the teams are
playing in the same competition for 15
10 or 20 years I don't know and we need
to catch up so we're gonna train harder
than anybody and I remember the first
year oh man we trained so much it was
impossible we were going to win a game
we trained it so much and on the second
year or third year we said like okay
boys we are the team that we travel the
most we travel like every week to
another country so maybe we should start
focusing more about recovery and not
training so much we that was some of the
learnings we've been we've done in the
road you know but it was everything
learning you could see the the year
before and we were like but we were
doing uh like nothing to do with what we
were doing the year before why is that
so we it was like change and learn
change and learn every time yeah and
yeah it was we were really proud to that
we played the final uh I think that if
the Jaguars keep on going we were going
to be a a strong team in the competition
a consistent strong team in the
competition because we were in a in a
good in a good path here so what what
did happen to them and and where are
they now like is it all over or is there
still hope to get them back
yeah
to be honest we were I was not the
after the fourth year uh on the fifth
year I went to play for staff francaise
but the the team stay more or less the
same the same and we were about to play
uh the Highlanders back home we were
already in the stadium it was a Saturday
so it was game day and we just they just
told us hey the pandemic start and I go
with stuff and they just told us uh the
New Zealand team has to go I think
straight to New Zealand because if not
they're not going to be able to to get
into the country because rules are
changing or whatever so we're not
playing the game and we were like what
why are not playing the game we're
already here like like it's like two
hours before the end yeah and after that
we never ever played it again like never
play again they just boom yeah just
rules change teams the tournament chain
because of the of the of the covid-19
teams start changing they didn't want to
travel too much they want to play more
uh
intern competitions and we didn't have
an indoor competition so the union just
came and said okay guys if you guys can
go and play anywhere in the world you
got a chance to play any other team just
go because we are not going to be able
to to
compromise and keep on paying your
contracts so there were players that had
like four-year contract three year
contracts and they just had to go and
find a another place to keep on uh
competing and playing rugby right so it
was crazy it was crazy crazy times but
yeah I think that make us stronger and
now looking backwards and seeing it all
we've been through and I think we we are
we're a stronger team and did everyone
get a contract or is there still quite a
few really talented players over in
Argentina who are sort of waiting for a
contract or an opportunity that probably
would have presented being presented if
they was if they still had the Jaguars
yeah I think there's we have a lot of
young talent that will be probably
playing for the Jaguars or playing Super
Rugby at the moment if if we had the
team
90 of the player found found clubs and
were able to go maybe not to the clubs
that they they would let to go but to
the clubs that they they got a chance to
go at that moment because everyone
wanted to keep on competing and playing
rugby uh so yeah now now it's more
stable uh after pandemic and after after
two years and a half players start to
find better clubs better competition and
a lot of young players of Argentina very
young players have a internal
competition that is called the slur it's
like a South American competition oh
yeah it's not as competitive as as Super
Rugby for sure nothing to do with Super
Rugby but at least for very young
players that want to to play some better
rugby it's it's a good a good spot to be
seen by the by the Pumas coaches or or
by the yeah
and you mentioned your move to start
Francais
um how did how did that move come about
why'd you why'd you head over there
well I always wanted to
play to be in France or to experience
something different I I remember
obviously my experience in Leicester
that
did touch me touch me ditch me teach me
a lot
taught me a lot and I said okay I want
to do it again now I was in a different
position in my life I was with a partner
already we wanted to do it together I
was struggling with it with traveling so
much and I wanted to I wanted to start a
family and I wanted to have a kid and
maybe with all the trouble it was it was
not not so easy I I could see the the
older boys that had kids how much they
suffer with all the traveling and stuff
I say or maybe his brother that I go to
Europe and live in the same country and
play in the same country and be able to
have a family so that was our project
so I went to France and yeah we had our
first kid there
and it was a great experience as well
learning a new language a new
environment
our rugby was maybe not the best at the
moment staff Francia was struggling a
little bit uh I remember I was contract
by Heineken mayor and when I arrived
like two days before I traveled to
France uh he got sucked from staff
francaise so when I arrived we didn't
have a coach or we didn't have nothing
so I didn't even know who to speak to to
get the game plan
to learn or to learn the calls or
whatever yeah it was yeah it was tough
times in Paris and but it was fun it was
fun how did your wife find living in
France did she enjoy it
oh she loved it yeah she really loved it
she loved Paris uh we lived there for
two years and we were we were offered to
stay three more years there yeah and
that's that's when I told her I think I
want to go and play in New Zealand and
she was like nah what are you talking
about I already learned the language
yeah I already did everything now yeah
now we've settled because every time you
go to a new place the first couple of
months you struggle a little bit Yeah
and then you start you start finding
your Rhythm you start getting to know
new people new friends uh be part of the
group and that's when I that's all the
time when I say okay now it's time to
leave
oh yeah she paid me for that but she
knew how how important how much me and
it helped for me for me to go play in
New Zealand yeah and obviously to go to
the Crusader so she understood and and
she knew it was it was my dream so
she was fine for that and now we we
don't regret anything like I think we
took the the good decision
so how did you get that contract at the
Crusaders it's not often
um players international players come to
New Zealand and play for a New Zealand
Super Rugby side so how did the contract
come up initially
well initially when we play the rugby
championship in 2020 and I heard of one
of my mates San Diego he's playing for
to lose at the moment that he was going
he was offered to go and play for the
blues oh yeah then because of the the
miq or the Visa or one of those things
he he was not able to go there and the
contract fell but that's when I say like
I thought it was impossible to play
foreign and after that I feel like oh
maybe it's not impossible maybe it's
hard but maybe there's a way
so I remember calling my agents saying I
want to go and play for Super Rugby and
in New Zealand
so he started working start talking to
some clubs and I remember our first uh
my first call with racer
I think it was like 7 A.M in
in New Zealand he was in the computer
and I could see like a cat walking at
the back and he was very relaxed and he
was like okay do you want to come the
Crusade and I was like I would love to
like 100
and they say okay okay we'll make it
work and that's it that's how hard it
was because I will make it work and we
didn't talk about nothing we didn't talk
about numbers we didn't talk about
nothing else he said like you want to
come yeah okay we'll make it work that's
it and that's that was the end of the of
the conversation and yeah everything
everything went really really fast but I
finished my my season in France in June
and I had to be in in New Zealand in
December and it was impossible to get a
to get an miq spot so uh I was six
months without club and when we were in
November I was like still didn't know if
I was going to have a spot or if I was
going to be able to go to New Zealand so
that was a stressful times I was very
stressful then I was like then I got a I
got a spot in MyQ for the like 27th of
February and I remember I was so happy
call racer and said like hey I found a
spot 20 27 of February and she was like
nah don't take it we we had our first
our first game is the 24th of February
but this is the best I can get if you
didn't if you didn't take that spot uh
you could still continue trying to get
another spot and maybe you you won't
have another spot yeah so we just took
the risk we said okay we're not taking
it and I was on the November tour in
Ireland when when I got my spot and it
says like okay in five days You're Gonna
spot for the next five seconds you need
to be in New Zealand so I just flight
from Ireland straight to Dubai my wife
was in Argentina she fled to Dubai and
from there we fly together to New
Zealand
we didn't have even even time to pack or
whatever we just said okay we're going
to New Zealand that's it
and yeah remember we were we were doing
the miq in Hamilton and you could see
all the the faces of the people they
were all like uh why we have to do a
week a week in a hotel or whatever and
we were like
we were so stressed for six months
trying to get a spot that we we don't
care if we didn't need to do anything to
to be there so so when when you got to
Christchurch you had you said you didn't
Peck or anything so you just had to
start from nothing find a house
um and get everything to to live I guess
yeah I think that the Crusaders is
amazing in in that way yeah because when
I arrived to when I arrived to the
airport they already we couldn't have
contacts because after I arrived and I
do my miq I still have to do like four
more days in in Christchurch of
isolation but my my car was already
there parked and
they already put like I already rent an
Airbnb and they went there and put like
food in the fridge they asked me what do
you eat what do you need for the next
four days what does your baby need for
the next four days so they sort
everything out so that was really
amazing that was something else like
something I I never experienced in any
other environment or any other team and
how much they care about the the family
that is coming to to the new club so
yeah that's how it worked and after
after my four days in quarantine I just
started training and involved with the
team yeah and how did you find the the
boys like how what was the what was the
differences between the Crusaders and
some of the other sites that you'd
played for
I was thinking I remember our first day
uh that we had to do some Fitness tests
and we finished our fitness test and
after that we started like doing rugby
drills or rugby skins and I was amazed
of the quality of the rugby session
because I said like
if I look back to any other team and we
we haven't been training together for a
month and we just did some Fitness tests
our rugby would be like
[ __ ] sorry for the word I don't know how
to say but our rugby wouldn't be like we
wouldn't have a good equality session
yeah and the the quality session there
was like spot on like really good
sometimes like we have I don't know a
Wednesday off we try on a Tuesday we had
a Wednesday off and we go back to
training on Thursday and I remember
having some bad sessions because we come
from a day off and that day I said like
okay these guys come from a month off or
whatever a couple of weeks off and you
could see the quality of the training so
I was amazed to be honest I was amazed
so that was one of the big impacts yeah
did you have to change your style the
way you played at all because it looked
like you looked lighter and uh obviously
you look like you're playing with a bit
more freedom and a lot of one-handed
offloads and I mean kicking game was on
point remember that kick in the final
but and did you change your style at all
now I was trying to put weight on but it
was impossible like they run so much in
training and even like they don't give
you like 20 seconds to go have a drink
so that's why I was looking lighter I
was running I was running all day like I
never run in my life more than when I
was 20. so yeah the first couple of
games I honestly I struggled like I said
oh this is harder than I thought yeah
the challenge was not in the Rock River
I was in the fitness wise you know the
physical it was very physical very fast
a lot of game time game time yeah so
that was the biggest challenge but I
think after the fourth fifth game I
started feeling better and being able to
play some rugby because I was not
playing rugby at all at the beginning
so yeah at the end at the end I really I
really felt I
I found my rhythm found my rhythm with a
team getting to know my teammates how
they play where they're gonna be and
I started enjoying my Rugby a lot how
much weight did you lose
I lost like 4kg oh yeah and you've put
that back on now
after two weeks
two weeks at home
yeah oh that's good stuff and and what
sort of players what sort of players in
that Crusaders environment really
impressed you who did you think wow this
guy is amazing
uh submaris yeah so that that guy is
something else yeah he can kick he can
chase he can run you can do whatever
yeah that was one of the guys that I was
more impressed
uh less terrifying an agua as well yeah
he's he's a beast obviously some white
dog the way the way he talks his his
mental strengths everything a lot of
learning from him as well
but either like his work rate is
unbelievable so yeah a lot of a lot of
incredible players yeah to be honest and
talk me through that kick in the um
final obviously a lot of people will
remember the way Grabber you put through
a big moment in a big game what do you
remember about that one
and not much to be honest I remember
it just happened you know when you don't
not thinking a lot but I just at some
point after after playing a living with
maybe Severus
I knew that you could just keep whatever
and he's gonna get the ball so that gave
me a lot of confidence to be honest that
gave me a little I could just throw a
[ __ ] buzzing keyword he's gonna grab it
and run 20 meters so at some point that
gave me a lot of confidence and I don't
know I just saw a space and just kicked
the ball I had to ride in my hand like
top kicking because it's something that
I always want to do even though it's
like my first option like okay no wrong
so I yeah I need to keep on saying
myself like don't do it don't do it
don't do it
but yeah I know it just happened just
happened did you did you play in the
back line when you were younger is that
where they're kicking your kicking game
come from or will you always a Ford
no I started playing Winger oh I did
yeah I was lighter I was a lot lighter
yeah I was more like a skater boy you
know yeah very light and fits and I
loved Running With The Ball I loved
kicking the ball because I love playing
football and I saw rugby should be
similar to football
and then I started playing when I went
to my first uh
Club here
they said okay this is a tall guy maybe
we play we play him luck so I went
straight from Winger to playing luck and
and then I make my way through to be
back in the background
yeah oh good stuff okay
um and I guess um I mean the next step
for you is obviously Honda how long is
your contract there with Honda
I got a one one plus one so yeah one
maybe two years without
whatever it goes what are your plans
post footy have you got much of an idea
of what you'd like to do
no really not really I think I want to
be involved with the game like I love I
love my uh I'll how my my life is now
about traveling about preparing about
rugby about being involved with a team
uh I enjoyed I enjoy a lot that so I
think I'm gonna do something similar
yeah I'm not sure would you coach
maybe yeah maybe right I could imagine
you being the coach of Argentina post
the Checker era
and steps
and where do you think uh the family
will settle you've mentioned you've been
all around the world you've lived in
almost every country possible and where
do you think the family is going to want
to settle
I don't know well I do know I don't know
if it's gonna happen but my wife just
loves Christchurch really today we were
talking about we were having some fun
and I told her like okay what would you
do if I yeah if if I die tomorrow what
are you gonna do and she's like ah
probably going back to Christchurch
what are you what are you gonna do there
you're gonna be very lonely there far
from Argentina far from family I said I
don't know I will be okay now we loved
our time we loved our time in
Christchurch we really enjoy enjoy it a
lot so I don't know I don't want to say
Chrysler but I don't know maybe in New
Zealand yeah yeah
you'll have to get back to the Crusaders
I'm gathered I'm not going to get to
work with you um next season but
hopefully I'm still there the year after
and right we'll have to get you back
hopefully I can still play some good
rugby after I got the beers and we'll
see yeah yeah no doubt you'll be on fire
still well anyway as always I've gone to
my Instagram where I ask um the
listeners for some questions and
um so many questions came in for you
very popular man and a lot of them came
in about one person so I've got 87
questions coming and 63 of these
questions were about this one guy who I
who I played a bit of rugby worth I know
he's an Absolute Pest he's very niggly
but it is Dane Coles talk me through
what happened after the test number two
with Dane Coles
yeah yeah that was that was not
something I proud about to be honest
because
I know there's a lot of young young kids
so young players that watch the game and
is is not uh it's not a good example
like uh I I I'm the one that or one of
the writers said like the thing that
happens in the field stayed in the field
yeah that's how it has to be always but
uh that day was a bit different to be
honest that there was a bit different uh
I think he came in when there was like
10 minutes left and he just continued
speaking on me uh in every Rack in every
ground saying some things that to be
honest it really hurt me yeah really
hurt me some some strong things I
uh I don't want to repeat it I don't
want to repeat it
but I couldn't understand why because
they were winning by 40 points he just
came in like I didn't understand why he
was with that attitude
uh but I know he's he's obviously he's a
great player but I know he's a great guy
as well because uh some of his his
teammates spoke to me after the game and
said like oh this is he's a good guy and
I said I'm sure he's a good guy I'm sure
but I just didn't understand why he he
continued picking at me and he said
seemed that I'm sensible about like uh
maybe in New Zealand like you don't
belong here and I was like if you knew
how much for me and my family did to be
able to come to New Zealand you wouldn't
be saying these things but uh yeah
that's it it won't happen again and even
though I didn't want to give the hand to
him because I can't take a disrespectful
uh I I have to I should have done it
because the game is bigger than any
player and there's a lot of young
fellows watching the game and the game
just need to be a
as clean as and as yeah as good as it
can be right I love that I I do know I
do know how Negley and how bad some of
his um as some of his banter can be and
yeah sounds like he he took a little bit
overboard in that game for sure
yeah it can happen
another another good learning for for
next time yeah if he invited you to go
have a beer with him would you go
um okay this one's from uh your good
mate Scott Steele and you mentioned him
at the list of tigers but
um ask him what happened to his white
bunny rabbit when he was playing at
Leicester
no well as I told you before when I was
doing Leicester I was
I didn't know if I wanted to stay or not
so I
I don't even plan I don't even pack or
or make a proper like moving back to
Argentina because I thought that maybe I
would come back and after like days gone
by and I had to leave so I just booked a
plane and after packing a few things I
said like okay what I'm gonna do with
the bunny like so I don't I didn't know
where to take it or whatever so I just
opened the door and release him he was a
free bunny now running Leicester I hope
that
I hope that he didn't got a hand by a
fox or something like that because
there's a lot of foxes around there but
yeah he was he's a free bunny now
so was this your pet bunny did you buy a
[ __ ] Banner oh we did the bunny Camp bro
no I didn't buy it I just went to a
place where they have a lot of animals
and they just if you want to take care
of it you you could take care of it so I
don't know I thought
I don't know maybe a bunny Cece so I I
got the bunny but I I didn't have a cage
or nothing so the bunny was free in my
house all the time and he keep on like
biting everything he he had all the
cables of the TV he had everything
everything that the even the wall was
like all you could see his teeth
everywhere
and it was not my house it was a rent
house now I can tell you why no one
wanted to run me a flat industry right
yeah it was
but yeah he was a free bunny and you
could be watching TV and you heard like
and the money was like running all over
the apartment all night running because
they're like night animals and yeah one
day I just set him free
well it's so funny did the landlord know
you had a bunny at the rental
no not really I'm the Lander I said like
I think I texted him when I was in the
airport already I said like oh I left
the keys at the at the door I'm flying
to Argentina today thank you for
everything
oh that is so good I love it man a
little white bunny okay next question
this one came in a couple of times have
you got such massive arms what's the
secret
arms yeah
but there was I I had a yeah I got a one
of the best conditioning coach was uh
Steph uh stats he's South African he was
the conditional coach for stormers I'm
sure a lot of South African boys know
him and he had a he was the fittest guy
in the in the team like no one could
pick him up Bronco and he's like I think
50 years old and he had a mentality that
said that no no biceps no rugby like you
can't play rugby
but no that's nothing that's not yeah
I'm not a I'm not a big a big gym fan to
be honest I'm not a big film I was a big
gym fan when I was younger uh now I'm
just uh I'm more like a recovery guy
I'm more about trying to be able to play
on Saturday
well I think everyone gets to their AJ
where you just recovery becomes the main
uh main part of um rugby yeah not
everybody man Cody Taylor I mean he I
remember him smashing the gym and watch
I I see how he could watch me and he
said like you don't like Jim huh
I said like nah I don't like you too
much
that's good okay next one this question
is from our major sponsor swish if you
could get a video message from any
celebrity who would it be and why
oh that's a good one
any celebrity
probably
Lewis Hamilton oh yeah yeah
Formula One yeah he's I'm a big I'm a
big red bull fan to be honest yeah my
first album but uh Louise Hamilton in
the last decade he's been unbelievable
one of the best sports man ever uh and
rather than that Michael Jordan yeah I
got one of his jerseys back home
that I I bought in an auction the replay
in the future yeah he's
[Music]
yeah I have it in the in my my kids room
he doesn't understand what it is but one
day he will
yeah do you so do you follow quite a bit
of other sports obviously you'll have a
bit of Formula One a bit of basketball
yeah not too much basketball but I I
obviously I know Michael Jordan but
Formula One yeah I love Formula One I
Love the the PlayStation game of Formula
One oh yeah a lot playing yeah yeah nice
and football obviously everyone loves
football and Argentina
yeah Argentina is just about football
rugby is so tiny you couldn't tell when
I went to Christchurch I said like I
said to my wife I think that more people
knows me know me here that they know me
in Argentina
everyone knows rugby Christchurch and
obviously New Zealand but in Christ are
like everyone remember my first day like
the the girl in the chicken say like so
you're that foreign player that is
coming to play for like I said like yeah
that's me I don't look too much to use
London I know my English is not that
good
oh good stuff okay two more questions
what was your favorite thing and least
favorite thing about living in New
Zealand
my favorite thing uh
I love the I love the Christchurch it's
amazing where you you got like 20
minutes you can be in the beach another
10 minutes you can be in the mountains
and how like there's a lot of things to
do with our family like I think
everything is is think to be able to do
it with young kids and you got always
the option of uh of being able to deal
with with young kids so we really had
the best time ever as a family I think
the worst thing and the most difficult
thing was the time difference we got
15 or 16 hour difference so
we we had a very short Gap
to be able to talk to family and connect
with family so there was a couple of
weeks where we just don't
spoke with anybody yeah and we're just
the the three of us there by ourselves
so that was maybe the hardest thing but
uh it's it's a beautiful place yeah we
really enjoyed it I love it okay last
question what's the best piece of advice
you have for a Waterland listener
foreign
that's the that's the thing I need to
employ in my English when you guys just
said like four words in one
you need to give a little pause between
words
I'm speaking your English has been on
fire like I I've been just speaking
completely normally like full speed and
you've just picked everything up so I
probably got a bit over carried it I got
carried a little bit carried away there
nah it's been good it's been good uh I
think the best advice is to I remember
when I was about to make the decision if
going to if going in to New Zealand or
maybe stay in France or and you start
putting a lot of things in the balance
you say okay maybe uh
uh our family Works my family going to
be better what's going to be easier or
where can I get more money or you you
put a lot of things in the balance but
at the end of the day though there's
like one thing that matters that it's
like what do you want to do like where
do you want to play it so I always come
back and ask like the the the Pablo with
15 years old that started to play rugby
and said like okay where would he want
to play so and it was like that make
everything so easy like well did Pablo
when he was 15 when I play or he
probably would prefer playing on the
Crusaders so yeah just don't think too
much you know don't sing too much just
do whatever you feel our your first
feeling
eighty percent of the time is the is the
the proper one the best choice and just
do whatever yeah just to do whatever you
you really enjoy and love doing right I
love that and you've obviously lived by
it because you have like we've spoken
about on the podcast being everywhere
you've experienced so many things you
would have met so many people from this
game so man it's awesome hearing you
living your story back mate really
appreciate you coming on the podcast
giving up your time
um I know you're a v you're a legend
here in New Zealand you're a Legend
um in World rugby to be fair so it's
been awesome getting an insight into
um your career and hearing a little bit
more about you
now thank you for inviting me I always
always enjoyed uh talking about rugby
and talking about life and it brings a
lot of memories back to me that I I we
with your questions and something that I
haven't been able to really think about
so thank you very much I really enjoyed
and I'm gonna be watching it whenever
whenever it comes yeah hopefully I'll
hopefully see you in uh Christchurch in
a couple of years you and your family
yeah I would love
to I appreciate it thanks
what an absolutely
[Music]
[Music]